wir haben vor kurzer zeit die situation
gehabt dass mehrere afghanische junge
männer ein 13 jähriges mädchen unter
drogen gesetzt vergewaltigt ermordet und
dann wie eine sache abgelegt haben das
ist einfach eine barbarische dass das
ist nicht in worte zu fassen das was
hier teilweise stattfindet man darf
nicht den fehler machen dann alle über
einen kamm zu scheren und zu
verallgemeinern aber es stimmt dass wir
mit vielen die aus afghanistan aus
tschetschenien und anderen teilen der
welt gekommen sind aus ganz anderen
systemen aus ganz anderen kulturkreisen
das ist hier massive probleme gibt es
das eine neue qualität der gewalt
kriminalität die daher
selbstverständlich ja selbstverständlich
sie müssen sich ja nur die nur die
kriminalitätsstatistiken anschauen
vieles was es hier an brutalität gibt
hat es in der vergangenheit so nicht
gegeben
die zahlen sind auch sehr eindeutig in
gewissen gruppen was was die häufung der
gewaltverbrechen betrifft was die
häufung von sexueller gewalt gegen
frauen zum beispiel betrifft
das ist etwas das darf man nicht
schönreden ich bin jemand der das klar
auch ausspricht und genauso wie nicht
verallgemeinern sollte genauso muss man
solche probleme einfach bekämpfen und da
gibt es viel was wir in unseren staaten
machen müssen aber ganz wesentlich ist
auch keine unbeschränkte migration nach
europa nach österreich und in andere
länder aber